[Music]  no one no matter how powerful they are  is above the law  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  sexual harassment derogatory comments  daily comments about what we were  wearing  foreign  [Music]  Whispers that a few owners went to Dan  Snyder over the last couple of weeks to  say to him it's time  in a statement of CBS News Snyder said  that he is acknowledged and apologized  for the unacceptable work environment  within the organization that we said the  lawsuit contained innuendo half truths  and lies the NFL called the lawsuit  legally unsound and factually baseless  saying Wilkinson's investigation was  thorough and comprehensive and resulted  in a record-setting fine  of 10 million dollars